in 1997 a massive gray cloud of gas and
smog settled over the ordinary town of
dale port new england phone lines were
cut off and any attempts to enter the
town were met with failure there was a
complete and total blackout of
information coming in and out of
daleport whatever was occurring it was
anything but normal and clashed with the
town's easy-going and peaceful
atmosphere an anomalous event of this
size and scale was impossible to miss
and naturally caught the attention of
the scp foundation before it did the
outside media who would report on the
mysterious occurrence and draw
unnecessary amounts of attention to the
town the foundation was lucky enough to
maintain a hold over the situation
little over three hours after it had
begun and they were already starting
their usual cover-up story operations
keeping the situation and daleport well
away from the public eye still they were
unsure of what was occurring and what
they were dealing with themselves if
they were going to get to the bottom of
this mysterious smog covering an average
new england town they were going to be
safe and have to play it resourcefully
as the scp foundation is known for doing
the status of daleport's residents
whether they were alive or dead was
completely unknown and so the foundation
began their rescue efforts a containment
perimeter surrounding the town was
established and relevant witnesses
outside of the town were detained and
amnesticized with convincing cover
stories already being deployed for the
foundation even an entire town
undergoing an anomalous event was
something they were well prepared to
deal with having handled similar
situations multiple times over the
decades the foundation began its
research on daleport by observing what
exactly the cloud of smog covering the
town was the foundation wasn't keen on
sending its personnel even the so-called
disposable d-class to their death so the
first exploration into the cloud was
carried out by an unmanned ground
vehicle operating under the call sign
ugv-1 this unstoppable carrier was
equipped with all the stops including
atmospheric sampling sensors audio video
recording equipment and an open circuit
biological sampling instrument which
contained skin tissue and several live
brown rats whose reactions would
indicate to the foundation whether or
not the smog was safe to be exposed to
or not the ground vehicle departed and
when it returned about a half hour later
it brought with it a whole host of data
about the gas covering daleport as it
turned out the smog was composed of
sulfur nitrogen and carbon oxides
concentrated at a level where irritation
would occur upon contact with humans but
it wasn't lethal neither was it
anomalous as the samples the vehicle
carried in with it were unaffected in
any anomalous manner the video recording
displayed a flat empty wasteland inside
the gas cluster with little discernible
features after a certain point radio
communication with the vehicle became
degraded and the foundation returned the
carrier to the town's perimeter as more
resources and supplies arrived on
location the foundation ramped up its
research efforts this time two d-class
were sent into the gas cluster both
aboard another ground vehicle carrier
this time the truck was equipped with a
higher wattage radio transceiver than
the first one which the foundation hoped
would be enough to maintain
communication throughout the anomaly at
a kilometer from beyond the boundary the
d-classes departed the vehicle and were
asked to remove their protective suits
they experienced no anomalous effects
from exposure to the gas but medical
telemetry showed that one of the
d-classes was having difficulty
breathing the duo reported the same flat
featureless terrain the first vehicle's
recording had captured when radio
interference occurred again the
foundation pulled the vehicle back and
the two d-classes were recovered safely
with no abnormal effects occurring as a
result of being exposed to the gas still
there was no indication of what was
actually occurring in daleport it was
only that lifeless grey horizon and the
foundation wanted answers a third
expedition was carried out this time
manned by mobile task force operatives
equipped with all of the latest gear as
well as several large vehicles the
vehicles split up but communications
quickly pointed out differences between
the team's surroundings one spotted an
upward incline while the others only saw
the same terrain as before minutes later
the incline team reported that they were
going down an incline the team that
hadn't seen the incline reported that
they were now seeing it and they were
following the other vehicle downwards
another team noticed red and blue
patterns in the sky while voices on the
radios began speaking in an unknown
language after minutes of radio
interference the foundation picked up
the sound of a firefight with mobile
task force operatives giving wildly
varying descriptions of the attacking
forces whatever was happening was
incomprehensible
and for whatever reason the foundation
was entirely unable to communicate
through the radios after around 30
minutes of noise an unknown voice gave a
mysterious gibberish-filled message to
the foundation it's a little silly to
hear but there's certainly some strange
undertones within the voice said
[Music]
evil has been summoned to this town by a
society of immigrants
the world shall be contained within me
by virgil and thunder
in
as i cannot keep them from the shock
then i'll throw thee for the leaders
i shall leave
and the shock will be yours again
i hope you shall
survive
it
it was clear that something had taken
over the town of daleport and that this
mysterious voice while threatening
sounding was apparently protecting the
people inside it mentioned that the
foundation's men were in safe hands and
that evil had been summoned to the town
the foundation didn't know what to make
of the message or if they could trust
the entity that made it but they didn't
have much of a choice they attempted to
send more unmanned operations into the
town but they were unable to reach their
destination somehow always winding up
back where they started shortly after
departing after a week and a half of
fruitless expeditions and no new
information the gas blocking the town of
daleport dissipated completely leaving
the town accessible and able to be
explored fully by the foundation a
containment crew fully set up a
perimeter around the area with secure
cameras and an entire facility on the
outskirts of daleport named area 37 to
oversee and support the foundation's
research efforts inside the town which
was now officially categorized as
scp-1936
with the gas now dissipated the
foundation began to investigate the
anomalous effects left in its wake the
town itself was altered with buildings
physically differing from their previous
states and a large portion of them
having become topologically inconsistent
there were rooms that would appear
bigger or smaller than they should be
with some growing so small after they
had been entered that they trapped
occupants inside and prevented them from
moving resulting in a number of
unretrievable foundation personnel
becoming stuck and lost inside the
anomaly forever other doors would lead
to different locations at different
times of the day or corridors that led
to multiple locations at the same time
despite only leading to one these
difficult to describe spatial anomalies
were so dangerous and unpredictable that
the foundation forbade any exploration
into scp-1936
without explicit authorization
but while the town itself was affected
what about the people inside it the
normal people who were caught up in the
anomalous fate of daleport what happened
to them the foundation was unsure and
while no survivors were found within the
town itself a large number of human
remains of daleport citizens were
recovered during the exploration efforts
most of these remains demonstrated
anomalous properties presumably gained
as a result of the devastating anomalous
disaster that plagued the town a week
prior some of the remains the foundation
recovered were incredibly strange such
as a smear of entrails found alongside a
small plant that gave out a constant
flame the pile of viscera picked up
radio transmissions from up to six miles
away with sound being created through
vibration of tissues another was a torso
embedded in the wall of a building
slight movement of the torso was visible
when investigating personnel spoke and
blood continually manifested in mid-air
15 centimeters above the torso on the
main street of the town several corpses
were discovered with their flesh skin
and bone all removed from a circular
portion of their foreheads skin and
brain tissue surrounding their wounds
had undergone severe charring outside of
the public library several floating
torsos manifest at certain times each
day simulating the motions of running
alongside the road after three minutes
the torsos attempt to leave the road and
fade out a young woman's body floats
steadily upwards when any force is
applied to it regardless of the force's
direction the body is currently
suspended 57 meters above the ground
floating over daleport and these are
just some of the strange anomalies found
within
scp-1936 while it's unknown what
happened to these civilians their bodies
were clearly affected by whatever
occurred the week prior while the
foundation was unable to access the town
of daleport something in that strange
anomalous gas triggered a highly
destructive event that had grave
consequences for ordinary people and the
foundation was none the wiser as to what
it was still they continued their search
of the area and over the next few weeks
they discovered a number of recovered
materials from the wreckage and debris
of
scp-1936 the first were a series of
written documents composed by the town's
previous inhabitants these were
recovered from laptops and journals but
read in that same nonsensical tone that
the mysterious voice spoken during the
mobile task force's expedition one note
said that the writer was running out of
canned food and that there was constant
screaming coming from outside their
house and something trying to break into
it the note talked about the town's
reverend described as having too many
spaces in him who was walking past the
writer's windows and ranting about total
nonsense the note also read that the
writer was fearing that as they put it
one of the big guys was coming their way
and that they could hear the pounding
constant sound of drums but one note
remains consistent found in multiple
locations throughout scp-1936
predominantly in public toilets and
stitched into the internal organs of the
daleport residents bodies it reads i am
so sorry that i could not save you
signed pangolos the foundation had heard
rumblings and rumors of the entity known
as pangloss who was supposedly a god
with a helpful affinity for humanity but
there was no concrete evidence pointing
towards the being's existence whatever
happened in daleport was pangloss trying
to stop it the message certainly reads
that way surveillance footage from a gas
station painted an even more terrifying
picture an ordinary gas station cashier
was doing his job ringing out a
customer's items when the window next to
him smashed open and an impossible
looking tentacle-filled entity made its
way into the building the tentacle
creature lashed out at the two of them
brutally murdering the customer with the
force of the impact of its slippery
writhing appendage the cashier hid
behind the counter but the footage shows
the entity also making its way behind
the counter and the gruesome visual of
blood splattering the walls behind the
register as the entity quickly took the
cashier's life but then mysteriously an
individual enters the gas station
wearing a bowler hat and a waistcoat the
footage distorts as they enter the shot
then their face is revealed instead of
ordinary features like a mouth or eyes
they have a triangle branded into their
skin the tentacle entity move back in
fear of this well-dressed individual
clearly afraid of them then a series of
multi-jointed appendages burst forth
from various points on the individual's
body and they lunge forward attacking
the tentacle entity the footage cuts off
there with the individual throwing the
tentacle creature through the wall of
the gas station whoever this individual
was it was clear they didn't take kindly
to the rampaging tentacle entity some
foundation researchers began to
speculate that the individual was
pangloss themselves who was trying to
save daleport as best they could but
there was obviously no way to be certain
of the mysterious person's identity more
footage showed a car crash outside of a
public library which resulted in a
spectral translucent entity breaking
free from the broken lamppost that the
vehicle collided into the car's
passengers immediately ran but the
ghost-like entity chased after them this
continues until the ghost emits a large
blue shockwave of unknown energy which
passes over the people turning them
completely transparent and causing them
to fade away the foundation recognized
that it was another mysterious surreal
entity rampaging through daleport
clearly whatever happened here was
anything but normal another collection
of footage this time focusing around
daleport's town hall depicted the
building in complete ruin the roof was
collapsed the front doors were missing
and the entire structure was toned in a
blue violet hue in front of the building
was a convoy of vehicles civilian trucks
and cars as well as the ground vehicles
of the mobile task force squads that
went missing after they were sent into
the anomaly it was clear this footage
took place shortly after the foundation
attempted to enter the gas surrounding
daleport and lost connection with the
task forces that were sent in the
footage shows the foundation soldiers as
well as the civilians of the town
fighting against another strange-looking
entity this time shaped like a fractal
structure eventually they retreat into
the town hall building narrowly escaping
from the strange creature and directly
into a circular blue violet vortex after
all the civilians and personnel have
escaped the phrase pangloss grants you
sanctuary is burned into the stonework
above the town hall's entrance it was
this footage that gave the foundation a
better idea of what occurred in scp-1936
though the strangeness of the visuals
didn't clear much up whatever disaster
happened in daleport whatever resulted
in these absurd hostile entities being
unleashed upon the town was actively
combated by pangloss the deity who was
trying its best to move civilians to
safety but one question remained if
pangloss was transporting civilians to
safety where did they wind up why did
the foundation not discover any
survivors inside daleport well their
answer came a few weeks later when in a
shocking turn of events 94 live
civilians and nearly all of the missing
foundation personnel manifested inside
the area 37 facility pangloss's
emergency escape method worked and the
civilians were confirmed alive and
without harm it's not very often that
missing persons are actually recovered
in the foundation's line of work so hats
off to pengloss for managing to do some
good in this horrifying situation
interviews with the recovered
individuals indicated that they all
suffered memory loss regarding the
events of daleport so unfortunately
there was no new information to be
gained from their recovery but inside
the anomaly foundation expedition teams
uncovered more documents and pieces of
evidence this time referring to a cult
named the victory society which the
foundation began to believe was the
cause of the mysterious gas arriving
over daleport and the town's destruction
little is known about the victory
society but it is believed to be a
religious organization that was
localized to daleport one note recovered
from the body of a victory society
member was a list of things that the
cult needed which included a strange and
ridiculous combination of items
including two trout a bottle of milk
beetles ice dead bodies human eyes and
assorted souls in the margins of the
note there were more personal thoughts
which the writer lamented the difficulty
in acquiring some of the objects another
note was found on the inside of the book
this time detailing a great religious
battle between gods and entities that
the foundation had never heard of once
again it was written in that lofty
nonsensical tone detailing an
all-encompassing mist that would descend
upon the world which would prevent those
from entering the location the text
described as the place where an event
known as the awakening would occur if
this text was to be believed daleport
was the center of a battle between
incredibly powerful extra-dimensional
anomalous entities who clashed together
with little regard for the residents of
the town it seemed that pangos the
entity who saved the civilians was just
trying their best to move as many people
as they could to safety away from the
havoc of the surreal battleground that
daleport was becoming more documents
this time from the victory society's
reverend leader detailed the cult
performing a ritual again and again the
reverend stated in this note that the
ritual was for in his words the good of
everybody and that the victor would walk
from the rubbles of man and restore
clarity to those who remain the notes
also included a transcription of a
speech given by the reverend in which he
addressed the victory society cult with
haunting premonitions of what would come
his voice painted a harrowing picture
brothers and sisters we come together to
bid farewell today it has been an honor
to work with you all
i could not have hoped for a better
group with which to secure the future of
mankind from the dawn of time terrible
impossibilities have spawned from the
darkness between stars not hate in life
simply being indifferent to it we are as
ants to these abominations these
demented gods they are so far above us
that we are but insects accordingly we
shall look as such in order to gain the
forgiveness in favor of the gods we must
learn to know our place before them each
of these things seeks dominion over the
laws of reality itself
imposing the nature of their twisted
existence upon stars and planets and
people the only answer to this threat
these gods must be destroyed the slate
wiped clean we could not do this by no
means no
but we cannot allow these things to
exist a kingdom cannot have a billion
kings we cannot kill the gods no only a
god can kill a god we will bring them
here and bind them bind them until their
bloodlust is satiated until all but one
is dead always a single god remains the
victor who returns to whence they came
as the only god remaining
and with that the mystery of daleport
was solved the victory society called
sought to wage war between the gods of
the universe until one victorious being
would emerge the town of daleport was
used as a battleground with all the
anomalous effects occurring as a result
of the combat between these terrifyingly
destructive entities and if you're
familiar with the deities that go
toe-to-toe with the scp foundation you
know these guys aren't a joke the
scarlet king and his legions of devilish
followers the almighty broken god and
the mysterious benevolent serpent of the
library are just some of the powerful
religious entities the foundation has
researched and catalogued and if what
came to daleport was anywhere near as
powerful as those examples it's a wonder
the rest of the world is still here
after the fact another piece of
surveillance footage taken from in front
of a church in daleport center depicts
these violent deities in combat with one
another beings of massive size and
incomprehensible shape battling with one
another in an ordinary suburban town the
victory society's goal may have been
incomprehensible and difficult to
understand but the foundation will never
forget what happened in the town of
daleport and the destruction these
impossible entities caused but a single
question remains we know that pengloss
transported some survivors from the
scene but what was the result of the
battle what happened the victory society
mentioned that a single entity would
emerge victorious from the battle but
who was it which god was so terrifying
so powerful that it slaughtered the
others and crowned itself king amongst
the anomalous pantheon
perhaps some questions are better left
unanswered now go watch scp-001 the
scarlet king and
scp-2217 hammer and anvil for more
terrifying destructive deities from scp
explained